hello to all of you listening to my
podcast
your attention is appreciated and never
taken for granted i hope you find it
challenging useful and engaging i've
certainly learned a lot doing it
as you might know
this show is ad-supported i have a
policy that requires all the projects
i'm working with to be financially
self-sustaining
this helps ensure their long-term
operability improves the efficiency with
which they are run and aids me in
prioritization
as an alternative however for those who
would rather listen ad free
we have now uploaded a premium version
of the podcast at a subscription rate of
10 a month
your subscription will also include
ad-free access to all four seasons of
previous podcast episodes a monthly ask
me anything episode for subscribers and
priority pre-sale access to future live
events
subscribe if you like at
jordanbpeterson.supercast.com
that's jordanbeterson.supercast.com
or scroll down to show notes and click
the link
after doing so the premium ad free
podcast will appear automatically on
your spotify or apple podcasts or
whatever other platform you might prefer
again you can subscribe at
jordanbpeterson.supercast.com
or scroll down to show notes and click
the link or you can continue to listen
to this free podcast with my wonderful
daughter reading ads from our wonderful
sponsors
thank you very much for your attention
[Music]
your bible lectures and your books have
a healing effect on people
people write about it in the comments
all the time because their lives begin
to order and they find new purpose in
life find something to strive for you
encourage them and it seems to be an
enduring effect it's something that
lasts for a long time
there are a lot of cases like that so
you can't say that's a random effect
it's a pattern
people who read 12 rules who watch your
lectures and especially those who have
read maps of meaning and the books you
recommend
experience rapid personal growth their
emotional state their health and their
relationships change i'm shocked and
surprised
yes we try to do it we're doing our best
and i can tell you that every day on our
different channels in different
countries people ask when will you post
the next bible lecture when will we hear
the maps of meaning and it's not fake
it's not generated by any kind of
advertising you know it's not something
artificially created
we were just trying to do our best to do
the best job we could
andrew and matt did a vast amount of
work for the channel
eric helped us a lot so i'm not that
surprised that our channel took off we
didn't use all those traffic boosting
methods we just took a very careful
approach to translation and quality of
the content
my team and i spent hours every day
talking to publishers from different
countries and to your fans from
different countries trying to figure out
what kind of translation they wanted
how should we approach the translation
what kind of voice is the best for the
voice over
we found a different tone for each
lecture and it worked in the beginning
we planned to make a single centralized
hub for video production
but we realized very quickly it will
sooner or later turn into a treadmill
and the quality and attention to detail
that are important for say korean or
arabic viewers
can only be provided by the team that
shares the same mindset as those
listeners
and so we almost immediately began to
hire and form teams within each country
that's how we created the korean team
that's how we created the arabic team
the russian team is now fully formed and
these are people who know their thing
very well
they know your works and lectures and
they are aware of all the things that
surround it
aware of the whole range of scientific
knowledge they need to possess in order
to properly communicate your ideas
i want to thank you very much for
introducing us to eric neumann for
example it was very interesting for us
to get acquainted with his work
i have something to say about that
so
i spoke with professor camille pelia
a while back a couple of occasions and
she's
one of the west's foremost
literary
experts
and commentators
and
palia
told me
independently of my like liking for for
eric neumann
that she thought the whole history of
universities in the west
would have been different
if
the english departments in particular
had read eric neumann
and understood him instead of jacques
derrida and michelle foucault
and i believe that to be the case and i
was amazed that she said that
that's something i had thought for a
very long time
neumann is extremely profound thinker
the origins and history of consciousness
is a remarkable book
and and so is the great mother and he in
some sense he provides a
well an overview and summary of jung's
thinking
which you couldn't get unless you read
like 20 volumes of jung it's all packed
into those two volumes origins origins
and history of consciousness and the
great mother
and uh
so i'm i'm
amazed but also extremely happy that his
work has been
more recognized because he's very
under-appreciated in my estimation i
mean his books have been in print
forever but
but he hasn't had the impact on literary
critics for example english departments
etc people concerned with literature
that he should have
second-rate thinkers instead
and he's not a second-grade thinker he's
a very deep thinker
he is a very good psychologist and the
fact that you mentioned him in your
works has inspired a particular interest
in him in russia viewers of our channel
began to buy books by eric neumann after
hearing about him in your interview with
camille palia
that's really good news
and also the fact that you mentioned him
in maps of meaning has sparked a lot of
interest in eric neumann
so the other person we should talk about
then probably is merce merce elliada
because his he has a three volume
history of religious ideas and it's also
a great work in my estimation i i really
learned a lot from everything i read
that merce eliade published
and so for people who are interested in
neumann he's another person to
to study in depth and the history of
religious ideas it's a three-volume
set and it's very readable it's easier
to read than jung and easier to read
than neumann
and
it provides a great
overview of
his amazing career as a surveyor of
world religions it's a phenomenal book
and so if people are interested in maps
of meaning they're interested in neumann
they're interested in that
it's an anthropological and sociological
analysis of religion but it's also
deeply psychological and it focuses on
meaning
so
it's in the same
vein of thinking and that's another book
set of books that that are very much
worth pursuing for anyone that finds
this kind of material captivating
we will definitely do an event dedicated
to mercha eliade
i think it will be met with great
interest
and so what do people what how are the
russian viewers responding to
the
more
to my reliance on alexander solzhenitsyn
and my
my use of
the events in the soviet union in the
20th century
i don't know how a soldier nissan is
regarded in russia now
people in russia have a critical
attitude towards him in general
solzhenitsyn is a unique writer
and this is recognized by everyone
however what he described in his works
is rather his point of view
it's a cry from his heart it's a work of
fiction
and the problem is that this work of
fiction began to be perceived as a
documentary and when the soviet union
began to fall
those who dealt the final blows to it
they did it in the name of solzhenitsyn
and it was really hard for the ordinary
people because after 1991
more than a hundred thousand enterprises
were closed down
overnight the country plunged into chaos
and for 20 years all the media kept
telling us that all the people in our
country were to blame for the soviet
union and that they had to redeem
themselves in the eyes of alexander
isaiah
in the eyes of the western world
and it caused people a lot of pain
because they weren't doing anything
wrong they were working in institutes
they were translating books they were
raising children and then suddenly all
the media started humiliating them and
the sense of guilt they tried to create
was so painful that after 1991 in the
90s there was a huge wave of suicides
people didn't know how to live their
lives anymore this information kept
being shoved in their faces they kept
being told that it was their fault that
people were being exterminated in the
concentration camps although they had
nothing to do with it
and that is why people have mixed
feelings towards alexander isaiah
and everyone understands that it was a
terrible time and a very difficult one
and this wound has not healed to this
day
and even now as we're talking as i get
back to those events so so everyone i
mean we see that i think we see that
everywhere
in the world now that guilt
in in the west in the united states in
canada
there's
a lesser
it's a lesser phenomenon i would say
than what you're describing and lesser
than what the german people felt after
world war ii
but
there are accusations of colonialism and
white supremacy and
guilt over
the terror the terrors of history that
brought all of us to where we are now
and i think that it's something that we
all
face in some sense as an existential
problem i mean there are permanent
existential problems death suffering
deceit
sin
and all of the catastrophes of history
that for better or worse put us where we
are now and
the issue of how each of us
bear guilt and responsibility for things
that were done by the culture that we're
part of say or by our immediate
ancestors or even by our distant
ancestors that's a very difficult
psychological question because we're
historical creatures the existential
psychologists following heidegger
i believe
talked about that problem as the issue
of throneness thrown as in t-h-r-o-w-n
you're thrown into the world all of us
and you're thrown into your culture
arbitrarily you're thrown into your
family arbitrarily you're thrown into
your body arbitrarily
and we all have to deal with that and
figuring out how to do that individually
is
very difficult i mean what i was trying
to do in maps of meaning was to bring
this down to and in my other books for
that matter was to bring this problem
down to the individual level because
each of us in some sense have the
capacity to do all the terrible things
that anyone has ever done
and you see that
manifest itself on mass very frequently
and that happened in the soviet union it
happened in
in germany it it happened everywhere
really
if you just have to look hard enough and
long enough in some ways and so
i i felt that it was necessary
it seemed to me and this was
so the question is what do you do about
that that that guilt that's part and
parcel of being a member of any
culture that has done things that
are reprehensible in the past and
the answer to that is try not to do it
to understand it and try not to do it in
the future
and so we we all do have that guilt and
we all do have that responsibility it
it's very difficult not for that for
that not to become overwhelming if you
look into it deeply and you have to look
into it deeply to some degree to scare
yourself badly enough into putting your
life together so that maybe the
probability of such things will be less
in the future
it's a very tricky thing to manage
so
i think maybe partly what you do is you
you regard it and this is what the
existential psychologists were pointing
to it's
it's part of the nature of being human
to bear that historical guilt
so it's impersonal in some sense you
still have to take it seriously and you
still have to do something about it but
but it's not
it's there's an impersonal and universal
element to it
and that makes it somewhat easier to
bear
i can say that a careful study of this
issue and your writings helped me to
cope with the feelings that arise from
the fact that some great guilt a great
burden is crushing me now
when i do not even know if my relatives
participated in these events
i know that they were repressed that's
something i know for sure
and i can't understand and many other
people can't understand what they are
guilty of when their grandparents were
the victims
you gave some very good advice about how
studying existential psychology can help
you get a broader perspective on this
issue
if i may ask a few questions
yeah well part of the problem so for
example there's this trope in in
this is particularly the case in the
united states that
all white people are racist
and that goes along with this claim that
american society in particular but not
only america european society in general
and that would include russian society
are
in some deep sense white supremacist
and
those accusations are variations
of
their variations of political thinking
emerging from
from this sense of universal guilt
the answer the the quest the answer to
the question are all white people racist
is yes
but it's also no
and here's why and
are all people racist
well yes
all of us
and why would i say that well
the anthropological literature is quite
clear on this
as far as i understand it
that virtually every
society that's ever been discovered
especially when they're isolated tends
to refer to
their own group members basically as
human beings and all those outside of
that group as some other category
and so and i think that's a reflection
of our in-group preference and our
ability to cooperate and form bonds
so it's not trivial and it's difficult
for all of us to extend
to immediately extend that sense of kin
and that's the root word for kindness
that extent that extend that sense of
kin beyond our in-group and it's also
extremely difficult because well how
many people can you actually attend to
and care for
you know you're limited in your scope
and so the answer to the question are
all white people racist is yes but but
it's it's still a bad it's still a bad
question
because the inclusion of the word white
implies that it's unique to say white
people and that's just not the case it's
true of human beings it's probably true
of our closest biological relatives in
in a profound and meaningful sense
chimpanzees go to war
that was discovered by jane goodall in
the 1970s it was a great shock they go
on raiding parties and if they outnumber
if small troops of generally juvenile
males go on raiding parties near the
border of their territory and if they
find a chimp from another territory
and they outnumber them they'll tear
them to pieces
and so this is a deep problem and we
it's all it's a problem for all of us
because it's tangled up it's actually
tangled up inside our goodness
that's also what makes it so difficult
because
the fact that i really love my family
members let's say and then
my community around that
that in some sense is also why i'm not
so positively predisposed to anything i
see outside of that that i think might
disrupt
disrupt it
and so
we have to have some sympathy for for
that
proclivity
and we need to understand what we do
about it now in the modern world where
it's
doing
more harm than good
because maybe we don't need to be
parochial in that sense
like we were in the past
and and perhaps we can't afford to be
because we're so technologically
powerful now that that
tendency to demonize the out group
member
that'll destroy all of us if if we don't
figure out how to get it under control
and so
i felt that the best because maps of
meaning the reason i wrote maps of
meaning essentially was to figure out
how you get that under control as an
individual
and that took me deep into religious
work and and religious morality i would
say and
i think the answer to that pro the
answer to the question of that problem
is that we have to become better people
we have to become more conscious
we have to become more conscious of our
ethical obligations we have to become
more conscious of
the nature of good and evil to put it
bluntly and
and we have to bear the responsibility
the ethical responsibility that our
powerful technology demands
that's also something i learned i would
say most explicitly from carl jung and
his he made the case it's a very
interesting argument that
he believed that the scientific endeavor
emerged out of the alchemical endeavor
and
he has his reasons for believing that
and i think it's a reasonable
proposition historically there's many
roots of the scientific endeavor but
newton was an alchemist so you know
there's there's one
staggeringly important example
an alchemy was a fantasy about the value
that might be lurking in the material
world and jung believed that we needed
to fantasize about
what value might be held in study of the
material world for thousands of years
before we could organize ourselves
psychologically to do something as
technically sophisticated as science
so but alchemy was still you know
one-tenth science and 90
imagination and religion in some sense
and then the the scientific part of it
blew up massively over the last 400
years and it's put us where we are
technologically but the ethical part the
religious part didn't blow up and expand
in the same way
but it has to we have to be as ethical
as we are powerful
or or we won't manage
and we'll destroy ourselves with
and maybe we'll do it because we want to
so
so we have to grow up in some sense and
and that means we have to become
conscious of things that we have not yet
been become conscious of and i think
that that
that means becoming more conscious
of what
what it means that there are religious
values
what that means ontologically so what
that means for the nature of being
itself and what it means in terms of how
each of us perceive and act
and what our obligations are and what
the costs are of not doing that we have
to become very serious about such things
in a way that we are not serious yet
most of the discussion i see about
the relationship between science and
religion
is the sort of discussion that takes
place between
the viewpoint that's put forth most
eloquently and powerfully likely by the
atheist materialists like dawkins and
and
and harris and daniel dennett
and as far as i'm concerned they're just
not contending with the problem what
they do is
they
there's a sleight of hand there's an
intellectual sleight of hand that's
unnoticed by those that they're arguing
against and the sleight of hand is
they implicitly and explicitly
presume that
the enemy they're fighting which would
be religious belief as such
is a fundamentally a set of propositions
about the
explicit propositions about the
structure of the material world in some
sense so it's akin to a scientific
theory
and then
having
made that presumption and having that
presumption not be questioned
they can
take relatively straightforward steps to
demolish it
but the problem with that is is that
well there's a variety of problems but
problem number one is
that first move is not kosher
because that's wrong
what part of what religious is is what
happens to you when you look at the
night sky in the pitch black and you
can't confront infinity
and there's an embodied set of
experiences that
that manifest themselves independent of
your will
and part of that is fear in trembling in
the presence of the infinite
that's the awe but there's also a call
in that there's an intrinsic call in
that
to greater being on your part
to be better than you are that's part of
that experience there's an ennobling
aspect to it and none of that is
rational and propositional
it's deep it's instinctive
it's part of the
instinct to imitate
and
serious scientists would contend with
that
and serious people would as well
there's a set of experiences that
ensnare all of us
dancing to music is another what are we
doing when we're dancing to music
well we don't know but it's and it's
easy to think of it as mere
entertainment or something trivial but
it's not i had a one of canada's
national treasures
here yesterday rex murphy very very
astute and profound person and he said
he this wasn't his
words
but he read them and remembered them
all art aspires to the condition of
music
yes
well what does that mean well it's
something outside rationality
greater than rationality
and every virtually everyone loves music
well what does it mean that they love
music why does that
why does that feed the soul
music
what exactly is going on there
well something profound is going on
there
it's something that's calling us to
align ourselves harmoniously with the
patterns of being
and this isn't this isn't none of this
is optional and the other issue is well
if the religious enterprise is failed
and anyone with any reasonable intellect
can see that
then from whence do we derive our values
exactly
because
the science i know
has convinced me
and these are the most serious
psychologists that i've read
of people like um
an ecological approach to perception is
that the book i can't quite remember
the title always escapes me gibson
nope gibson nope gibson gibson gibson a
visual approach
i can't remember the book
eric maybe you can just look that up
briefly it's it's uh it's gibson
perception
anyways gibson was quite convinced that
we perceive meaning not objective
reality and he didn't mean that he
wasn't a religious thinker
that was his conclusion from studying
the visual system in depth and it is the
case we see the world through the lens
of value
where do we derive from where do we
derive our values and more and maybe
even more importantly from where should
we derive our values and you can say
science yeah but that's a facile answer
and it's a dangerous answer too because
it risks the politicization of science
and science strives at least in some
sense to be value free and and
and
perhaps for the better and perhaps
that's a necessary part of the sense
scientific enterprise
but we need values there's they're not
optional
the necessity for value is built into us
at an unbelievably deep
level
biologically
not conceptually not as a secondary
consequence of our rationality none of
that it's a precondition for perception
itself
and we haven't wrestled with the
significance of that discovery now you
see
the
the earth shattering
significance of that discovery
manifested itself in part in the
realization of ai artificial
intelligence engineers
that it was virtually impossible to
build an intelligent machine that could
perceive the world unless it was
embodied and the reason for that was
that the problem of perceiving the world
was way more difficult than we thought
because we thought we just saw the
objects that were there the material
objects that were there
but that isn't how it that isn't the
case
it's really not the case it's so much
the case that if you try to build
a machine that perceives the world
that's just looking at the objects that
are there so to speak
you can't
it doesn't work and so people like
rodney brooks mit robotics engineer and
a genius
he started
figuring this out in like 1992 that in
all probability
a machine would have to be embodied to
perceive
because perception is so tightly cl
associated with action
and action and perception
are also so tightly associated with
value
you can't perceive without a framework
of values
where from where do we derive our values
from nowhere and are they real or not
well what do you mean by real exactly
you can't see without them so they're a
precondition for the perception of
material reality itself
and then we also know we all know we all
know this
some values are more important than
others
some things are deeper than other things
we all have that sense we know the
difference between a shallow story and a
deep story and but we don't know what we
mean by deep and we don't know what we
mean by shallow but we mean something
and so then i would say well the deepest
values are
religious
that's a definition
it's an observation
and so when i could say we should scrap
the entire religious enterprise as
intelligent 21st central century
rational intellectuals
but
well what about all these other problems
they don't they're not going away
and they're not the in they're not
problems that are imagined by some
codery of superstitious religious
scholars
these are profoundly difficult
scientific questions at least in part
the problem of perception
and then the problem of depth well are
some values deeper than others are some
values more basic than others
that means there's a hierarchy of values
and that means there's something at the
top
that unites it all or everything is
fragmented those are the alternatives
and then so one of my propositions is
that well what christianity is
psychologically speaking at least in
part
is the attempt to specify the nature of
the highest value
and part of that's an abstraction
and so that's what god is in the old
testament is
an abstract representation of the
highest value
and then there's another problem is once
you abstractly represent the highest
value how do you bring it down to earth
so that it can guide your actions and
the i the notion of the incarnation is
the
answer it's at minimum it's the answer
provided by the collective imagination
of western civilization to the problem
of the embodiment of the highest value
and are we gonna what are we gonna do
are we gonna be are we gonna be children
in the face of that
or are we going to think about it
because it's a problem
but one of the things
eliad pointed out was
he was commenting at least in part on
nichi's observation of the death of god
and elliot said well god god has died
time and time again
because
one psychological problem with
abstract ethical
religious thinking is that the highest
value can become so abstract that no one
can have any relationship with it
anymore
you don't know how you don't know what
it means for you you don't know how to
act it out you don't know how to embody
it and so it's meaningless it disappears
it floats away but then
when that happens to a culture there's
no central unifying value and then the
culture fragments that's in that
in in a manner that's analogous to the
tower of babel in some sense
and so something has to serve as a
uniting value and it is the highest
value
and i don't i do not believe that the
rationalist types the rationalist
atheists i don't believe they contend
with these problems at all
they and it's not because
it's because they don't understand them
they don't know these problems exist
they exist
these are
fundamental problems
and when i say that christianity is the
attempt to answer the question of how
the highest abstract value should be
embodied i mean that most seriously
and then you ask yourself as well you
know you said to me earlier that
the people who've been translating the
biblical lectures
have experienced some transformation in
their own life
it's that's because they started to
embody the
the ethic
i can tell you like
are you going to strive to embody the
ultimate ideal
or not because i could ask you do you
have anything better to do
how could you possibly have anything
better to do and if you don't want to do
that why don't you want to do it well i
don't believe in that it's like
what do you mean
by that
exactly do you not believe there are any
values
do you believe you can just pick and
choose
do you believe that there's no uniting
values and if there are uniting values
do you believe that you have an ethical
obligation to act in accordance with
them or not and then what do you think
will happen if you don't because i know
what will happen if you don't
you'll fall into a pit
and you'll drag the people around you
into the pit with you
and as you suffer because you're in the
pit
you'll delight in the fact that you're
there and that you've dragged all those
other people in there with you
yes you
you reminded me now it's the ecological
approach to visual perception and gibson
none of that book is religious in nature
in fact quite the contrary but it
doesn't matter because what it shows is
that
a value structure is a precondition for
perception itself
and i should say that over and over and
over a value system is the precondition
for perception itself
you were talking about people dragging
each other into a pit and it reminded me
of peter brogle's painting the blind
leading the blind but they all fall into
a pit
it really resembles people who don't
want to see these values and don't want
to aim for them
well what look what happens
how how could failure to bring
values under a unifying principle lead
to anything other than fragmentation and
confusion and i studied geoffrey gray's
book the neuropsychology of anxiety
which is the best book ever written
about the biology of anxiety hands down
and it's a hard book it took
psychologists i read that book in 1985
which wasn't very long after it was
published and i really read it it took
me six months to read that book it was
hard
and it took the general
run of psychologists
30 years to really notice jeffrey gray's
book
there wasn't a lot of serious discussion
about it
among personality psychologists and
social psychologists people who were far
removed from biology and animal
experimentation
it took 30 years for them to start to
digest that book and that process
certainly hasn't uh finished yet
and so
when i say that fragmentation of the
value structure
necessarily leads to a predominance of
negative emotion pain anxiety suffering
in general i believe that to be true
biologically and i think i understand
obviously not completely but i
understand the outlines of the
neurobiological reasons why that's the
case i wrote a paper with my students a
while back trying to tie
the the phenomenon of anxiety to the
the thermodynamic principle of entropy
and i think we were quite successful to
put physics underneath the site the
science of anxiety
and i think we were successful in that i
mean the paper was published in a very
good journal psychological review and as
far as i know no one's you know come up
with a
thorough going and serious refutation of
the proposition
if you fragment your value structure
then you're overwhelmed you become
overwhelmed by anxiety and that's the
price you pay for not being integrated
so fine you don't have to pursue
value
intensely and seriously you don't have
to devote yourself to it you don't have
to worship the highest ideal but the
price you'll pay for that is
fragmentation nihilism enemy existential
angst doubt
terror stress
more rapid aging all of that so fine
that's the alternative and that's only
on the personal level it says nothing of
the sociological level
your books help readers become more
integrated with themselves
in the great mother neumann says that
only the individual with integrated
consciousness can help the society
become healthy
only through individuals with integrated
consciousness can society properly form
and become healthy
what tendencies in modern society do you
think contribute to the and that's no
different by the way that is that is no
different
than
the statement that the imitation of
christ is the
highest ethical demand placed on every
individual in western society it's the
same idea it's exactly
the same idea
the first idea the christian idea is the
dream that preceded the psychology and
that's i'm and that's what it is
minimally
that's what it is minimally that's what
it is psychologically i'm not speaking
as a religious thinker
when i make that claim
i'm not trying in some sense to tread
into religious territory not not not not
as a theologian
i'm trying to explain something
and and to make it real and you know
and to make it real
what tendencies in modern society do you
think contributes to the integrity of
consciousness and what tendencies
interfere with it
some of that guilt that you were talking
about that that can be extremely
corrosive
you know one of the things that i was
extremely affected by when i went on my
tour
i i think this is part of what made me
ill although it wasn't all of it but it
was it was definitely part of it
was
i saw
i was offering people words of
encouragement and
it seemed that
the people who are benefiting most from
that in some sense were young men
and i think maybe that's because they
have been
formally criticized so much in the last
30 or 40 years
so they had the the deepest hunger
and and and i saw how
much hunger how much
thirst there was for words of
encouragement in the face of that
accusation
and guilt
like we all stagger forward under our
burden of sin that's the archaic
language and modern people well they
don't really understand what that means
and yet
they're discouraged and guilty about the
conditions of their own existence
and that's the same thing
and so then because i was offering words
of encouragement because i would rather
that people did
well than than do badly and and i mean
that most sincerely
it was stunning how much impact that had
on people and how grateful they were for
it
and that was very painful to me
to observe because i had no idea that
the hunger was so deep
and that people were so
hopeless because
they had been
crucified by their own guilt and by
their accusations of their insufficiency
and
the the malevolence of their ambition
let's say i mean i experienced that very
very personally a friend of mine
who was a very intelligent man
someone i knew from the time i was about
he killed himself and he did that at
least in part because
he believed that
masculine ambition
was fundamentally malevolent
and so
he didn't trust his own
forward striving and he couldn't
distinguish let's say greed from valid
ambition
and
i mean he wrote a story that really
affected me he was quite a good short
story writer as it turned out he only
had one
story published but i have his
unfinished novel
he wrote a story about
a memory he had when he was about 10
years old 11 years old something like
that he lived in this northern town high
prairie there was a large indigenous
population there it's a town very much
like the one i grew up in
and he was he got beat up by a group of
indigenous kids or one or two or one i
don't remember exactly the details of
the story but he didn't fight back he
wouldn't fight back because even at that
age he regarded himself as
his very presence there as a as morally
untenable
and you know fair enough there's a real
ethical conflict there europeans did
come to north america and south america
and 95 of the indigenous people died
from plague you know measles mumps
smallpox
and so that was an absolute catastrophe
and then
well the relationships between the
europeans who have come to
the western hemisphere and the
indigenous people have been fraught with
conflict to say the least
and no one's exactly sure how to
rectify that
but he viewed any sign of
masculine ambition let's say as
fundamentally immoral because of its
association with colonial domination and
technological
nightmare and the despoiling of the
planet and
all of that struck him to the heart you
know lit
killed him i mean there was more going
on but that was a big part of it
and so we bear this terrible guilt
all of us
and it interferes with our rise with our
ability to rise up
and all of that has to be
sorted out
you know we have to distinguish between
valid ethical striving to make the world
a better place and immoral ambition and
we have to be very careful that we don't
look at those who have
put themselves together perhaps
better than we have and have been
successful because of it and
warp our morality because we want to
tear them down because as examples
they're examples that we fall short of
it's very easy for this sort of thing to
become warped by resentment and hatred
you know you see this
i think i saw an example of that in the
united states alexandria ocasio-cortez i
i'm probably pronouncing her aoc i'm
pronouncing her name wrong
she wore a dress to a met gala big fancy
artistic affair
white dress like a bride's dress in some
sense and on it painted in red was taxed
the rich
and i like
that's an example of that
political twisting
it it it puts itself forward as an
ethical statement that's aimed at the
betterment of the lives of the poor but
lurking underneath that is a hatred for
those who have been successful and an
insistence that anyone successful has
only become successful because they've
exploited and hurt others and sometimes
that's the case
in some situations
probably for all of us
but sometimes and always are very
different and i've i've studied deeply
the political consequences the the
consequences
of that attitude going too far
that what happened to the kulaks in the
soviet union is a perfect perfect
example of that
kill all the successful farmers
because all they did was exploit
despite the fact that all those people
were serfs like 50 years previously
kill them all
take what they earned
what happened
six million people die
it is a very difficult thing with the
kulaks this is still a very painful
subject for millions of people in our
country
i can tell you that my family suffered
from it my relatives were dispossessed
like that
everything they had was taken away from
them
they worked hard for decades
and that being said the story is
actually more complicated than that
there really were such people in the
villages who were actually called kulaks
who lent to other peasants and then
forced them to give back much more than
they gave in the beginning
i mean they demanded from debtors so
much that people could not pay back the
debt
that's why kulaks were hated in the
villages because they were basically
users
and they could hurt or kill those who
delayed or didn't pay their debts
the authorities turned a blind eye to
this and sided with the kulaks they
could do anything they wanted to the
poor so when it started there's no doubt
there's no doubt that
economic exploitation occurs and
there's no doubt that economic
exploitation occurs there's no doubt
that
not all
material wealth is
is
is gained in an ethical manner all of
that
that's why those those discussions about
oppression and exploitation
always continue there's always some
truth in it
the thing is now it is perceived as a
sort of collective pain and drama i
think someday the pain will pass
unfortunately this whole phenomenon the
dispossession of kulax is now perceived
and interpreted rather superficially i
would say
it was much more complicated than that
and the fact that there was a
fratricidal war the civil war
that occurred before it makes it even
more complicated
there was no right and wrong there were
victims everyone suffered you know i
wanted to ask you about beyond order
we have already translated it into
russian
and i think there's a very important
point in the eighth chapter
the translators and the editors
especially liked it
it's about beauty
dostoyevsky said through one of his
characters that beauty will save the
world
why do you think beauty is so important
i think i think i'm so glad that that
that that's the case i think that was
the chapter that i liked the best of all
of both books
so i'm very i'm very pleased to hear
that that's been the response
and and part of that was motivated by my
contemplation
regarding dostoevsky's statement and and
solzhenitsyn's comments about it
what does that mean
well it means
it's a variant of the idea we discussed
earlier that all art ascribe all our art
aspires to the condition of music
it's it's akin to our discussion about
the night sky
beauty is something that it calls you to
that higher unifying ideal
it calls you and and it it pulls you and
part of that is is a manifestation
technically speaking of the
of the imitation of the instinct to
imitate human beings are unbelievably
imitative
unbelievably imitative it's our it's our
main cognitive transformation i would
say i mean every word we speak is the
word that everybody else uses that's an
example of the depth of this imitative
spirit
we were so good at imitation
and i'll give you a quick example of
that
so
if you watch a child who's three or four
years old
playing house male or female
the females will usually act out mother
and the males will act out father and if
you casually observe that you'll say
well they're imitating but that isn't
imitation if i imitated you i would sit
like this
that's imitation
because i'm precisely mimicking you
but if i'm what if i'm four years old
and i'm watching my father
for four years and i'm watching disney
movies that feature kings and so forth
so i'm getting an image of the father as
such
i'm abstracting from each particular
example of the father
the commonality of behavior and
perception that characterizes
the father across all those instances
and i when i'm pretending to be the
father i'm attempting to take that
abstraction and embody it
and that someone a four-year-old is
doing that it's unbelievably
sophisticated
and so the four-year-old is called to
manifest the spirit of the father
and it doesn't take much imagination to
see that transformed into a religious
statement
to be called to manifest the spirit of
the father it sounds like a religious
statement but that's what four-year-olds
are doing when they play house
they're very sophisticated
now that imitative
instinct imitation that instinct to
imitate is so deep in us that we'll
we're called to imitate things that
aren't even animate so when you walk
into it when you see a cathedral and
then you walk into the cathedral the
cathedral is calling you to imitate it
and the beauty beauty is part of that
call and it grips you
it's pointing to this higher unifying
ideal
and that's why and the fact that that
higher unifying ideal is so vital is
what accounts for the fact that beauty
compels
and it's pre-rational just like music
you can't argue with it
i mean you can say
you could say i suppose that well
all
all uh opinions about beauty are
arbitrary it's just subjective something
like that you could you could brush it
off
intellectually but it just means you're
shallow and you're not paying attention
beauty is mysterious and it's not
completely subjective because there's
wide agreement at least in some
instances on what is
spectacularly beautiful
i mean you can see that with the
pilgrims that flood into europe and you
think well they're not pilgrims well
what do you think the tourists are that
go to europe if they're not pilgrims
what do they go look at they go look at
beautiful things
and they've fallen out of the religious
landscape to such a degree that they
don't even know that they're on a
pilgrimage and they don't even know that
they're called to worship beauty and
they don't have any idea that that's a
call to a higher form of being
because we because we've cr shallowly
criticized our religious propositions we
don't even
understand when they start to manifest
themselves in an embodied manner and and
pull us here and there it's happening
politically all the time
so beauty it the reason that that
dostoevsky you see it
it's interesting to consider the
difference between dostoevsky and
nietzsche in this regard because
their
ideas are very similar in many many ways
they're like ones more rational and
explicit and one's more narrative and
literary but they're like the same
spirit
and and but dostoevsky is in some sense
deeper and i think nietzsche would have
agreed with this and i know that
nietzsche know knew more about
dostoevsky than people thought there's
been recently scholar scholarly work on
that account
dostoevsky
in some ways was closer to beauty his
work was closer to beauty than
nietzsche's because dostoevsky's work
was literary and artistic and so he
dealt in that aesthetic realm
and
the idiot for example it the idiot's a
very interesting book because
and and you see this in in other
another bits of dostoevsky's work as
well is that
his his most ethical characters can lose
every argument with rationalists and
still be better men
and you see that in the book because the
book allows them to be embodied rather
than mere carriers of propositional
arguments
and beauty is non-propositional and so
it it goes under our
our our
narcissistic
and blind
rational intellect that over values its
ability that's the spirit of lucifer
that milton warned everyone about
it goes under that and grabs you
and if you pay attention to that then
it's a it's a pointer
to what is beyond your understanding
and so it's vital it's vital and
dostoevsky knew that and solzhenitsyn
read that and he thought i see i see
what he means i understand what he means
and you know one of the characteristics
of our modern culture especially in the
architectural realm is that it's replete
with ugliness i mean i've gone to
medieval villages in europe especially
in east what used to be east germany
that were so beautiful they just made me
cry when i was it was when i was in the
downtown i thought my god this is so
unbelievably beautiful how did people
manage this
and and to think about all the effort
that was poured into those cathedrals
monuments to divine beauty what
imagination those people had
and what commitment and we we can't do
that modern people can't do that
and so it's a terrible loss and it's
partly because we just don't take such
things seriously and that's that's a
that's a big mistake because they are
more serious than anything else beauty
that's more serious than anything
except perhaps truth
but it's a pointer you know in these
religious thinkers
philosophically speaking christian
thinkers they thought of god as the some
some bornum that the sum of all good
things
well truth is something
and and beauty is something and courage
is something these virtues that we all
recognize as virtues or are tormented by
our conscience if we don't
you sum those all together that's the
ideal that binds us all
and that's god for all intents and
purposes you might say well is that real
it's like well it depends on what you
mean by real
and people laugh at me because i say
that sort of thing fairly frequently you
know it depends on what you mean by real
but when you ask the question is
something real it's like an equation
and the right response to that is well
what do you mean by real
and you think well that's an evasion
it's like no i'm just not accepting your
presuppositions as a precondition for
this discussion
you can't use that sleight of hand
so beauty it's like that beauty tells
you to be more than you are beauty tells
you to aspire to that which is beyond
you beauty says there is something
beyond you all of that
and it does that in an enticing manner
right it invites you to come along it's
the opposite of authoritarianism
it's an invitation it's like the most
beautiful woman you can possibly imagine
waiting there for you
on the dance floor
inviting
you that's beauty
and that's an invitation to be the sort
of man who could dance with that person
you think you don't take that seriously
like you get rejected by some woman you
you admire that her beauty has
captivated you and you're rejected
because you're less than you could be
you think you don't take that seriously
it's a
miracle you don't cut your throat throat
you take it seriously you just don't
know it you don't know what you're what
she's angry about why is she react
rejecting you
because you're not all you could be
and some of that's laid at your feet
and men are angry with women all the
time because that's what women do
that's what they tell them all the time
and it's a terrible thing
but can you blame them
what else would they do and what else
would you want them to do you know
in your shallow thoughts you'd think
well i wish that i was always accepted
every advance was accepted uncritically
well
that world would be hell very rapidly if
it was actually the case
i wanted to ask you about your work on
beyond order
our translators and editors have pointed
out that it has a very distinctive
language and many levels of complexity
to explore and comprehend
the peculiarity of this language is that
it somehow helps the reader set his
perception
set his mind on the book's narrative
it flows very easily and deeply into the
reader's mind is there a special
technique you use when you build up a
sentence
because we were comparing this book with
your other works and we noticed that
your wording has changed a bit it became
even more accurate
even though it seemed like it couldn't
be any more accurate but it became even
more vivid and we all enjoyed working on
the book
well that's remarkable that you said
deep in a light way when i was teaching
at harvard
i i was really concentrating on my maps
of meaning course although i paid plenty
of attention to the personality course
as well and they fed into each other
quite nicely
i was struck by this idea one day and
maps a meeting with such a serious
course because it dealt with atrocity it
dealt with the worst evils that i could
extract out from the last hundred years
of history and
that's pretty dark
and so it was very serious heavy and
maps of meaning is a heavy book there's
there's not much humor in maps of
meaning and i had kept having this idea
that i should
if i would had really mastered this
material i could present it in a manner
that was light and i thought well how in
the world could you possibly present
such things in a manner that was light
it's not like i don't appreciate the
necessity for humor i love talking to
comedians the the most enjoyable
interviews i've had and i think probably
the most successful ones in some ways
have been with comedians and the people
i grew up with i had a group of close
friends
from say grade 8 to so i was about 13
until i was about 20.
there's five or six of them
and
all we ever did was try to make each
other laugh all of our interactions were
wit competitions essentially and some of
them were way much funnier than me one
friend of mine in particular randy
carlstad was he was
so insanely funny i saw him again on my
50th birthday and he made me laugh so
hard i i could literally i could hardly
breathe he was so funny and so i love
the humor and most of what i watch on
television is stand up comedy or or
idiot humor like the trailer park boys
or something like some low brow
horrible low brow show like that which i
really enjoy
so there's something to this lightness
that's crucially important
and i don't i haven't quite puzzled it
all out
i know when i'm on top of things that i
can maintain my sense of humor and i
haven't always been able to do that
especially in interviews
you know over the last five years
because they
well for a variety of reasons
for a variety of reasons sometimes it
was the vitriolic nature of the
interactions and so forth but i know
when i'm at my best that you know i have
a sense of humor and i can keep things
light even if they're deadly serious and
i'm very happy to hear that
the translators have seen
that combination of lightness but but
depth in improve
as i continued to write i wasn't sure
about that i i wrote
beyond order under very uh trying
conditions i was unbelievably ill while
i wrote that book i
um
tara it was terrible
so i'm glad that that that worked
because i didn't i had no idea if it
would but i'm very happy to hear that
that's been the experience of the
translator because they're obviously
interacting with this text in a very
serious way
and i'm thrilled that that it was
chapter eight in particular that was
most affecting because
that was a particular favorite of mine
that that issue of beauty is so it's so
unbelievably crucially important to
to what's happening in the world today
because of what it
what it implies
so
you know that people wonder
what the purpose of such things as
classical music what's the purpose of
classical music let's say you say this
about any musical form and i like a very
wide variety of music
well
you know and you see this with
psychologists even psychologists i
admire they tend to just
wave their hands about the entire
cultural
capability of of human beings as if all
of this entertainment music drama art
literature that some
it's just entertainment you know that's
all it is
it's not in the central part of our of
our function as human beings or the
central part of our culture it's
completely backwards it's absolutely
backwards it's
it's
crucial and vital
so the lightness well that's good you
know and as i've become more healthy
recently
in the last month i've recovered a lot
thank god
i can think again a bit and
my sense of humor i'm hoping will come
back and
and i hope i can maintain it i'm going
on tour again i think next year
perhaps for the whole year and
it would be nice to have a hell a sense
of humor
while that's happening and
that would be wonderful
i would love to see you in russia if you
are willing to do it
that would be wonderful people here like
you very much they like you and they
would love to meet you
i would love to do a lecture in st
petersburg and so when we plan the
europe european and
that's not the only place but i would
particularly love to do a lecture in st
petersburg
um when we plan the european tour we
will definitely
do everything to make that happen
definitely it would be such a striking
honor and privilege to be able to do
that i
can't believe that that's a possibility
i would love to do it and the fact that
i can speak with russian people and
speak with people all over the world
this is a miracle really it's amazing
that and that you all are doing so much
work to make this happen and that you're
trying to be so careful with your words
i i'm so happy about that it's it's so
great you know and that part of that
transformation that you were talking
about
perhaps part of that is a consequence of
everybody trying to be very careful with
their words
it's it's it's not for nothing that our
entire culture decided that the
essential hallmark of the highest
uniting ideal was the word
we should take that seriously
the word is divine your word is divine
if it's true
think about that what if that was true
what if that was actually how reality
was constituted
you think you have no relationship with
reality with the infinite where are you
going to find that other than in truth
and and where are you going to approach
truth
more particularly than with your words
or evade or evade
the truth
with your words and so insofar as you
have a relationship with reality and
with the infinite and with truth
how could that not manifest itself in
the word
so it's crucially important to pay
attention to to what you say
and
and that's part of what we've all been
trying to figure out
for thousands and thousands of years
trying to understand what that meant
trying to make what's most important the
word the truthful word that's the most
important thing
really
well that's what we've concluded this
immense religious exercise
and i'm speaking as a psychologist
and it's amazing because the approach we
took it worked the same way in different
languages
lectures in chinese were received just
as well by the viewers as they were in
other languages and it's amazing all the
kind words people write to us they say
that it's an amazing translation and
that they've discovered a whole new
world and new meanings in life
we were all very impressed by that
and all we did was we were just trying
to be accurate trying to avoid adding
something unnecessary something of our
own invention during the translation
process we strive to convey the author's
vision and ideas and it works
i can tell you that every time the
translation deviated from your precise
sequence of phrases the book made a
completely different impression and it
somehow became harder to relate it to
the next piece of your work
that's how neatly it is structured
we noticed it when we were working on
the bible series and on beyond order
we realized we cannot change your
wordings and your choice of words
otherwise the book loses its depth and
energy
it's like we had to follow some kind of
star everyone felt that
it was something elusive
it's hard to put into words it's like
music like some sort of magic
and when we did it right the text began
to flow and it is so pleasant it is as
if everything connects with each other
and it is impossible to turn away from
it
some lectures that we have translated
and dubbed we listen to again and again
you want to get back to them to take a
deeper look into them you know
and that's the way we translate it
beyond order it's a book that you want
to read all over again to get back to it
i think we'll make sure that every
library in russia has this book that
people have the opportunity to read it
because by maintaining the sequence that
you have laid out
it's like we're giving people the
opportunity to enter another world to
get a deep insight into it
so my son and i and and a team have been
developing software to help people write
so it's a it's a word processing program
but it's it's it's a tool to write
more effectively
and it has technology that enables
dragging and dropping of sentences and
dragging and dropping of paragraphs and
modules that help you reshuffle and so
and it's based on
i i spend a lot of time developing an
explicit theory of writing and and also
of
say
text criticism because i had to grade so
many essays i i wanted to decompose the
grading process and understand what i
was doing and formalize it and so then i
started to understand that a text
it's a it's a multi-level phenomenon a
book
word phrase sentence paragraph sequence
of paragraphs chapters sequence of
chapters totality it exists at all those
levels simultaneously and although you
walk through it like you walk through
life from beginning to end as the author
you have a god's eye view and you can
see all of those structures
simultaneously you can see the end
even though once you've written the book
even though it has a beginning and what
that means is that you can make the
beginning refer to the end
you can make the end refer to the
beginning you can make all the parts of
the text refer to each other and one of
the things that's absolutely remarkable
about the bible
is that it's hyperlinked like that
there's a there's a map that an image
online that shows it's beautiful images
looks like a rainbow in some sense it
shows how many
references to each
verse
are made throughout the text
and so the bible is the world's first
hyperlink text thoroughly hyperlinked
text all of it refers to all of it
explicitly and implicitly and the reason
for that is because it's been reworked
and reworked and reworked and reworked
to be made somewhat coherent to be made
into an actual narrative by you know an
untold number of people working over an
untold amount of time the old stories in
the bible like the story of adam and eve
and the story of noah god only knows how
those how old those are i know that
historians literary historians perhaps
that's the discipline have traced back
some fairy tales ten ten thousand years
more than that and so and and one if a
story is ten thousand years old it's
probably a hundred thousand years old
because things didn't change much ten
thousand years ago
rights
not changing was how things were not
changing and so god only knows how old
those stories are and how long they were
told for
and so
when you write
if you think about what you're writing
deeply you start to make everything
refer to everything else and that's part
of
what makes you experience a text as deep
because
it's refers there's there's all these
references
within the text if the writer has done
his or her job properly and
edited at every one of those levels of
analysis
which is which you have to do
to is the word precise is the phrase
right are the phrases sequenced properly
in the sentence is the paragraph made of
properly sequenced sentences etc and i
edited all those levels explicitly over
and over
over and over and with with maps of
meaning i think i probably wrote every
sentence 50 times like i literally i
mean that literally i'd write a sentence
out and then i'd write another version
of it then i'd write another version of
it continually until i couldn't
until i started generating variance and
i couldn't make any qualitative
distinction between them
so i'd write down three and i'd say i
can't tell which of those is better so i
guess i'm done because i can't
make a finer value distinction now i
think i probably overworked maps of
meaning to some degree because because i
did that so
continually
some of the sentences are very long they
work but because they're so long they're
hard to it's hard on the reader and i
you know with that book i was trying to
figure something out i mean i wanted to
write a book obviously and i want to
communicate with people but
fundamentally i was trying to figure
something out with 12 rules and beyond
order
i i was taking what i had figured out
and trying to investigate it further but
i was also trying to make it much more
accessible it was much more a
communicative attempt rather than a
investigative attempt
so and i'm so happy i think part of the
reason your trans translations have
worked is because of this emphasis on
precision you said you're not playing
any tricks you're not trying to get
false attention and thank god for that
you definitely don't want you do not
want unearned attention believe me
that is not something anyone with any
sense would ever wish for because if
it's unearned
all the people who are devoting that
attention they will figure that out and
they will not be happy with you
and so the catastrophe will be
exactly proportional to the degree of
attention and the degree that it's
unearned that's not a good idea and but
you also from what you told me
he also realized that you had to really
meet your audience halfway you had to
you had to understand
locally the
the vernacular of the community and you
and you had enough humility to notice
that that was necessary you know i was
just talking to somebody a couple
economists the other day about the
failure of foreign aid the constant
failure of foreign aid and
part of the reason it fails is because
it's like well here is what we know and
you you ignorant people can just do it
whereas for it to work there has to be a
real deep study of the local environment
and and and and some
attention paid to how these things could
be integrated with that environment in
an inviting way and so the fact that you
paid attention to those local
particularities and that you
you know you said you only tried to be
precise here and now well that was how
the translation came through well that's
not only that's
man
if you can do that all the time
you're attending to the moment you know
accurately you're trying to establish a
relationship with truth accurately every
moment so that's not only that's
that's a that's an act of worship that
only trying to be precise here and now
and we could talk a little bit about
that too because
what worship means is imitate
and you think well you don't worship i
don't worship anything because i don't
believe in anything it's like oh yeah
you think that's true you don't think
you're imitating who are you imitating
no one oh you're a completely singular
person are you you know there's nothing
you're imitating
it's like think again
sunshine
you're imitating you just don't know who
you're imitating and maybe you should
figure it out because you might be
imitating something you do not want to
imitate
i also want to ask you about the period
you were working on the book
your daughter michaela was a great help
to you she always is
she hosts a very interesting podcast she
always chooses relevant topics
we watch her podcasts and see that she
is constantly growing
what helps us stay so strong and keep
people interested and engaged in your
opinion
first yes she's been unbelievably
helpful to me and she's saved my life
but i could say that of many people i'm
not trying to devalue what she did at
all i'm in fact i thanked her profoundly
last night for saving my life literally
and her husband as well andre who went
far beyond the call of duty caring for
me amazingly remarkably
inexplicably even but but i've had many
many many people have
have been of
great aid to me my wife
so a variety of close friends
all sorts of people have really gone out
of their way and so
michaela had to overcome a tremendous
amount of obstacle in her
short relatively short life so far i
mean she was unbelievably ill as a child
and she had 38 affected joints by
rheumatoid arthritis and she was in pain
all the time and like
she basically walked around on two
broken legs for like a year when she was
a teenager for a variety of reasons
joints had deteriorated both in her hip
and her ankle
to the point where they were non-fun
almost non-functional and and the
waiting times for surgery were very very
long and it wasn't even clear that they
could be fixed and her prognosis when we
found out what she had
i think we discovered that when she was
about
six or seven was multiple early joint
replacements and she was put on an
anti-arthritis medication a new biologic
she was the first kid in canada who got
that medication as it turned out and it
really worked it so she had a reprieve
for about five years but then her
hip
disintegrated and then her ankle
disintegrated and
she and she also has suffered from very
serious depression which runs in my
family on on my paternal side
particularly extremely serious severe
depression and it affected my father and
his father and a variety of of my
relatives and
and me and and my daughter not my son
thank god
so
she's had to overcome a lot and
she has overcome a lot and
she's
trying hard
and so
more power to her as far as i'm
concerned and i'm thrilled to see what's
happening with her podcast she seems to
be
uh have enough humility despite her
confidence to
not presume most of the time that she
knows more than she does and to ask you
know genuine questions and not to play
tricks and
and i hope that that that that's working
well for her and
um
yeah she's she's she's been extremely
helpful to me and mason made some very
wise decisions over the last few years
under very very difficult circumstances
for example i was written into a comic
book in april captain america which is
part of the underlying mythology in our
in the west now
the marvel movies have become so popular
and they are presenting mythology
essentially to a whole new generation i
was written into captain america as
uh red skull you know king of the evil
super nazis it was quite the shock
to me and
she helped me
weave my way through that
quite
successfully you know we we put out
we put out a
line of red skull merchandise and
devoted all the profits all the way all
that we made to charity and that was a
good that that was good it was a nice
kind of a judo move in some sense you
know
we didn't go on the attack
because why that's not helpful it's not
like i don't wish tanahisi coats the
best because i do he's the person who
wrote the
comic it's like i don't want bad things
to happen to him i hope that he
straightens up and
flies right you know because that would
be better for everyone and so it was a
tricky thing to manage and she was very
helpful in doing that and so
she's written she's written a book about
her experiences and she's going to
hopefully
i haven't read it yet i don't know if i
can read it
i don't know if i'm healthy enough to
read it yet but
she's investigating all the
possibilities that lie ahead of us in
this video frontier too and this is so
exciting because look at what we can do
it's crazy what we can do you know one
of the things we're talking about right
now i talked to her about this last
night is i was and i talked to
a couple educators about this
you know right now
we could put our collective resources
together for for a relatively small
capital outlay and we could produce a
curriculum from kindergarten through
grade 12 of the highest quality
educational material possible
right because who cares if we spent a
million dollars per hour i think that
maybe you know tens of millions of kids
could use it for god only knows how long
it would be wouldn't cost anything and
it would be basically free
and there's absolutely nothing stopping
us from doing that
and so
we're starting to think through how well
we could maybe initiate that program you
know and that's what faculties of
education if they had any sense at all
which they don't generally speaking and
i don't say that lightly
they'd be all over themselves right now
thinking look at what we can do we've
got this free video technology
that enables us to produce material that
everyone can access for nothing and we
could we could we could scientifically
determine how to propel students through
learning at the fastest possible rate to
cover the deepest possible material over
the course of their educational career
and to be completely engrossed while
they're doing it we could do that
and that technology that's only been
technologically possible for the last
five years let's say
there's nothing stopping people from
doing that so
you know hopefully i'm hoping i'll be
healthy enough to engage in some of
these projects
this is a very important issue
and i wonder how we can teach our
children to learn and help them develop
passion to learn new things it's not
something done in a snap do you have any
idea how to achieve this
i don't think i can tell you how how
it's possible to do that um
you know i can only speak at the level
of the family in some sense well and i
guess it's slightly broader i mean
the maternal role that's
there's a
that's a in some sense that's
fundamentally protective it's security
and
and physical well-being it's more than
that but but that's part of its core and
the core of paternal care i think is
encouragement
as far as i can tell it's more than that
and and of course the paternal and the
maternal overlap i'm not trying to
segregate them completely and so
you love and protect your children and
you encourage them to go out into the
world and that's
that ethos should permeate
our educational material although it
isn't obvious to me that it should be
taught explicitly if it isn't if the
material isn't saturated with those
intents
then that message won't be transmittable
anyways you know you already said when
you're doing these translations you're
trying for precision well there's an
ethos then that permeates the
translations insofar as you're able to
embody that and we want to do that with
the educational material that we produce
and i think probably the way to do that
is to make it
beautiful compelling engaging deep rich
uh accurate
and
to have the notion of what's being
served
firmly in the background surrounding all
the attempts to make the material and
love encouragement love encouragement
and truth let's say that's not a bad
triumphant to meditate upon when
contemplating educating children you
know what would you teach them if you
truly loved them and you wanted to
encourage them and you wanted to tell
them the truth
so what would you how would you teach
someone in grade one what would you
teach them obviously it would rely to
some degree on stories i think the first
thing we're going to try to do is to
i i
is to produce video material to teach
four-year-olds how to read
because if you can really teach kids how
to read they're going to educate
themselves a lot
so and
i i've seen material produced by
behavioral cognitive psychologists who
are effective
that
enables a four-year-old who's ready to
be taught how to read and write in three
months
with 10-minute lessons per day and it
works it's a really i know the program
it's a really good program it's
brilliantly designed it's a phonics
program and it's completely scripted and
i think it would work it might work on
video and then everyone could have it
and so that would be a good place to
start you know because everyone should
be able to read i don't think we're
going to get a lot of disagreement about
that
you brought up the topic of higher
education and establishing proper higher
education programs do you think modern
academic education continues to yield
the same great results that it used to
or does it require some changes
when i went to university i had good
professors and bad professors and i had
the best professors i had were at a
little college i went to to begin with
it was called grand prairie regional
college and it was in a town of 25 000
in northern alberta and only had about
500 students the professors really loved
to teach and i had great professors i
had the two years of education i got
there were
the best two years of education i got my
life i think although i learned a lot in
graduate school but that's a whole
different story that's that's a
different kind of education
um
so when when students go to university
now
when i went to a larger university i had
good professors and terrible professors
and it was sort of incumbent on me to
shop and find the professors who could
really teach as far as i was concerned
or who were teaching what i wanted to
learn and and to differentiate between
them and i think that
that hasn't changed in
in any profound sense what i've seen
happen
over the last 30 years in higher
education in in north america at least
is that it's got
much more expensive especially at the
high end and much more
much more politicized and
much
more laden with bureaucracy and
and
but i still believe that you know what
just a
discriminating and serious student can
go to a good university and and get
educated if that's what they're aiming
at a lot of that's up to the student
themselves
um
having said that i would also i would
say
however this tech the technology that
we're using right now
is absolutely revolutionary
because what it means is that
the best lectures teaching the deepest
material
can now go direct to everyone
and so that's that will have a
revolutionary effect it it can't not
and i you know i the the response to my
channel
to my video efforts is a reflection of
that because i was an early adopter in
the educational realm of this technology
you know and i did it partly as a
just an exploratory foray i had
these 13
programs that had been made by a small
ontario television station tv ontario
about maps of meaning
and they were professionally edited and
came out quite nicely as
reasonably digestible summaries of the
maps of meaning lectures and i thought
well i'll put them on youtube and see
what happens and you know back then that
was like 2013 i think
youtube no one knew what youtube was it
was place for cat videos no one took it
seriously
but you know i kept an eye on i thought
well this is interesting this is
permanent this is everywhere this is new
this is not
just
cute cat videos not that there's
anything wrong with those
but
and then i watched my you know the
viewership rise and rise and rise and i
thought well
there's something to this and then i
started having my courses filmed for
that reason it's like i thought well i
might as well teach everybody if if
they're interested
and that's another thing that's lovely
about youtube is the only people that
watch are people who are interested it's
like perfect students you don't want to
watch don't watch if you want to great
you know and and that's available for
everyone and
again to hope this is dependent on my
health but we're hoping to
talk to
great lectures everywhere and
to invite them and say look you know
what would you really like to teach if
you could teach anything you wanted
what would you really love to teach
because you should teach what you love
it the fact that you love it is an
indication that you should teach it and
maybe even that you that you could teach
it because you can invite people say
look i love this and this is why it's
like maybe you'll love it too maybe you
won't because not everyone doesn't love
everything that's for sure
but
so what i see the future of education
it's like the best lectures possible
about every topic conceivable
produced in the best manner possible
for everyone
for nothing
because we can do that too
and it's going to happen
it's going to happen
assuming we have any sense like why
wouldn't it happen why wouldn't we do
that
what a deal that is and then you know
there's a there's the problem of
accreditation but
that's a solvable problem
you know one way of solving that is to
get a panel of experts like real experts
in any domain and say well look produce
five thousand multiple choice questions
that you think cover the entire
territory or sample it at least you know
because you don't have to ask every
expert about everything you just have to
randomly sample their knowledge
well then you build a system that
randomly takes those questions and
aggregates them into exams and if
someone wants to be accredited they take
the exam or maybe they take three of
them and then their score is
number correct
it's absolutely accurate it's absolutely
reliable
you know you have a sample of their
knowledge and
maybe then 20 tests like that or 50
tests like that gives you the equivalent
of a bachelor's degree
something like that the accreditation
problem is solvable
and without that much expense
now you might say well multiple choice
tests don't test everything it's like
that's true but they can sample pretty
well
and
there are other
the problem of how to teach people to
write is a more complex one because
it's really hard to
grade an essay because you don't just
write b minus on it you don't just write
a percentage you have to tell the person
what they did wrong and if someone can't
write they did everything wrong the
words wrong the phrase is wrong the
sentence is wrong the sentences aren't
aggregated properly the paragraphs don't
make sense they're not sequenced
properly the whole essay is a mess
and you know to to explain why that's
all wrong to someone it's easier just to
rewrite the whole essay it's far easier
so but this is partly why we built this
writing program because we thought well
maybe one of the way to teach people how
to write is to build how to write into
the tool they use to write
and so we're hoping that we'll launch
that in the next three months something
like that the program is done
for all intents and purposes we
we
we're still figuring out how to
communicate about it and
we're not sure it will work because it's
it's a very complicated thing to produce
a writing technology and we might have
got it wrong i mean we tried to pay
attention to the user experience and all
of that but my sense was the best way to
teach people to write was to give them a
tool that would help them write better
because that can be scaled right and
it's it's dirt cheap it doesn't require
someone to
do the grading which is we can't
automate yet you know you talked about
more mechanical translation it doesn't
work it's not subtle enough it's not
nuanced enough and we can't use
automated systems to grade essays
we don't have the technology for that
and i don't know if we ever will we
might it's possible i doubt it because
i don't know how you could grade an
essay without being human it's so maybe
if we built a machine that perfectly
mimic being human it could do it but and
maybe it's a solvable technical problem
but i doubt it
we'll see
machines are getting smart quick
so i hope the future of education the
higher education it's like
experts who love their material
share their love with everyone for
nothing and i i would make a business uh
for nothing means it would still run on
a profit basis because i think that's
the most efficient way of doing this
but fundamentally the cost would be like
1 100th of a
standard university education
so now that doesn't solve the problem of
the
collegial
experience of university and
the mature maturation that occurs when
you leave your group of friends and make
new friends and the transformation of
personality that moving
enables and finding a new group of
people to associate with and the
introduction to the world of culture you
know
but
i don't know how to port that online and
and that might be the most important
part of the university experience
but on the mere merely educational front
well all this technology beckons
so
i wanted to ask if you're going to write
your next book and if you are could you
tell us what it will be about
yes and then i should stop because i'm
starting to get tired and i'm not going
to be able to provide any intelligent
answers soon but i'll answer that
question and then we should stop i am
working on a new book
it's tentatively titled we who wrestle
with god
and i took that title from the biblical
lectures when because i discovered for
my i discovered so that other people
didn't know this
that the word israel
meant we who wrestle with god and and
that's embedded in the narrative of
jacob wrestling with god or wrestling
with an angel it's a very strange story
for a rational person it's like what the
hell is going on here this jacob is
wrestling with god
or an angel it's not exactly clear in
the story what does that mean
and then his leg basically gets broken
or dislocated at least it's like well
why would god do that it's like well
all the atheists that are watching my
biblical lectures they're wrestling with
god more than religious people usually
they're more obsessed with the problem
we all wrestle with god it doesn't
matter if you're a believer or an
unbeliever
it doesn't matter at all
and you think that you know wrestling
with god won't break your leg it's like
you're bloody lucky if that's all it
does
so that's us man we who wrestle with god
so this book is about what that means
and it's also about what it means if we
don't know that that's what we're doing
and and and one thing i'm very concerned
with is the
is the sacralization of politics so
there's this
comment by christ that we should render
unto god what is god and unto caesar
what is caesar's and i believe that's
true psychologically as well as
politically
and the consequence of not doing that
isn't that god disappears and we all
become
proper thinking rationalists the
consequence is that
all sorts of things that should be
secular and profane get inflated with
religious significance
and then we can't even talk
you know because someone who has a
different political opinion
than you isn't merely on the other side
of a rational argument about how to
progress towards some agreed upon future
they're
they're like possessed by the spirit of
malevolence itself as far as you're
concerned because you haven't got
your categories straight
and so it's about that too it's like
there's a religious domain
i don't care if you're a believer or an
unbeliever
that statement is true
and if you don't think it's true then
you descri defi decide how you would
describe the experience of awe
well that's not religious it's all right
use whatever word you want but it's
going to come to mean religious
so it doesn't matter because the central
characteristic of the phenomenon of awe
is what we call religious
it's part of what beauty points us to
let's say so you can change the surface
terminology but it's not going to affect
the underlying reality
well
it's going to affect reality and it will
get confused but
the issues aren't going to go away
and part of what's happening in the west
right now it's not good it's really
dangerous is that
we're having religious discussions
disguised as political discussions
that's not good
it's really not good it's really
dangerous and and we have to be very
careful
and it's going to get worse i think
before it's going to get worse for a
while
so brace yourselves
thank you very much for this
conversation i really appreciated
it was a profound conversation
well thank you for for enlightening me
as to the extent of this translation
enterprise i really appreciate that
i really appreciate the fact that you
brought up and are attending to
precision
and and your description of the care
that's being taken i really appreciate
hearing about the effects that you've
observed and the discussion we had about
that
um i'm thrilled beyond belief that this
is happening i can't believe it
it's unbelievably remarkable and uh
hopefully we're trading a good path and
if we're careful all sorts of good
things will happen and i'm thrilled that
i can
i know that i'm be able to communicate
with people in russia and all these
other countries it's
such a privilege it's such a privilege
and so
remarkable
so
thank you for the intelligent questions
thank you very much goodbye i think we
will continue our conversation if you
have time
we have a lot of questions a lot of
questions from different channels
people really want to talk to you when
asked to ask you these questions and i'm
sure it will be just as fascinating as
this conversation
let's definitely definitely let's do
that collect the questions figure out
which ones you think are most relevant
absolutely let's do that
thank you very much jordan goodbye
bye
[Music]
you